the Israeli Army says at least six
soldiers have been killed in the latest
battles with Palestinian fighters in
Gaza they include a major and a captain
killed in the center and south of the
strip Hamas has released footage of its
Fighters confronting Israeli forces
Israel says 156 soldiers have been
killed in Gaza since the start of its
Grand offensive at the end of October
Israel said that it's expanding
operations in central Gaza as we've been
discussing Alan Fisher joining us live
from occupied East Jerusalem so we're
here hearing more that Israeli
reinforcements are being sent into Gaza
what more can you tell us about
that well there there's six brigades
operating in Gaza at the moment clearly
the hot spot as far as the Israeli
military is concerned is in and around
canun they believe that that's a Hamas
strong point they believe that if they
can capture Kan Yunis then the rest of
the battle will become much easier and
they are moving a battalion into a
brigade rather into help with the fight
right there in and around Han units this
comes within the last couple of hours as
the Israelis announc that three more
soldiers had died a sergeant a Corp a
captain and a major two of them killed
in that Central Gaza region one in
southern Gaza but it's certainly an
indication that this war is going to go
on for a while yet particularly in that
Central area and particularly around
canun six brigades would tend to be on
the large sky size of an operation for
the Israeli military the fact that
they're sending another one into the
area specifically heading to that
Central Area particularly canun shows
that just how intense the fighting is
around there the Israeli Army have
talked about how Hamas has been very
good at Guerilla fighting how they've
popped up from tunnels and attacked
Israeli soldiers clearly before they can
move on to what they call part C of this
operation they have to control canun and
that is the focus of the operations and
it sounds as though they are
re-emphasizing all the time the fact
that this war is going to continue for
for many more months what isra Israel is
saying about the the actual operation on
the ground and with this the focus now
shifting to Central and Southern
Gaza well Benny Gans who's a member of
the war cabinet remember there just
three ministers that fill the roles
there uh he has said that the Israel the
Army has done incredibly well done a
remarkable job saying that many people
criticized them saying they weren't
trained for this operation they weren't
ready they didn't have the equipment
instead he said they've performed as he
said with unprecedented results uh he
says that they have managed to in his
words kill thousands of terrorists and
destroy a great deal of aass
infrastructure and their tunnels but he
warned that this fight will go on for
some considerable time he said we
started uh ferociously but now the fight
has to be powerful and deep now the war
cabinet has been given it approval from
The Wider security cabinet to make the
decision of when it moves from Stage B
of the war which we're seeing at the
moment to Stage C and Stage C is meant
to be much more targeted a move away
critics would say from the mass killing
and to much more surgical strikes in
southern Gaza they have to do that quite
simply because so many people have moved
into Southern Gaza the sort of war that
they're carrying out just now is almost
impossible to imagine and certainly
would great bring a great deal of
international criticism remember the
majority of the population in the Gaza
Strip is in the north they have been
moved to the South the south is normally
overpopulated anyway now it is all the
people from the north so you can
understand just how condensed that area
is but clearly it's up to the war
cabinet to make that decision of when
they move from B to C but they say it
could be a number of weeks yet so you're
talking well into January before we see
this war change it the face Alan Fisher
and occup body East Jerusalem Alan thank
you very much indeed